do you think Liam would make a good  prime minister without doubt but too  good looking for this for ugly hey yes  be no  I've oh  no the right I wouldn't because I'm too  good looking for that stuff but anyone  to do a better job than the dude that's  in there now so I think the wrong one  will be your first policy what would you  I'd have to just put a law in and just  gaffer tape sculptures mouths just like  that and then I've also write Champions  across what would you do  definitely I know what else would the BM  man united fans followed quickly second  and that I'm not getting political on  that but voting for governments just I  would if I was prime minister I'd ban  all governments and just let and just  let people use the common sense you know  what I mean you don't need governments  tell us what to do